the jurogan experience is this
particularly
offensive to you because i mean it must
be because of your background and
you briefly talked about that but for
people who don't know you
i would like you to explain your
upbringing
where you came from and how you had to
literally risk your life to escape that
so i was born in somali in 1969
and growing up in the 70s my family went
to saudi arabia we went to ethiopia
we went to kenya that's where i learned
english and then
finally in 1992 i ended up in the
netherlands
but if you ask me in the context of
science to tell you about
those years between you know when i
could walk and talk and
understand what was going around me
until
about 1992 when i left
i come from territories where
superstition
is it's the thing to do you know
my father left us in 1982.
he left us in kenya he went back to
ethiopia to fight
for what he felt was his calling
a democracy and a justice system for the
somali people
but in kenya my mother who was with my
grandmother her mother's mother they
felt
abandoned in a strange country and they
didn't understand what was going on and
they had the three of us
the three of us that is my older brother
and my younger sister
and as children go we were terrible and
i remember
my mother going off to see witcher
doctors
and ask them how do i
how do i deal with my daily life
and those witch doctors would want one
thing
which was whatever money she could give
them and if she couldn't give money then
it would be her goat
or it would be something that they
treasured
and in kenya i'm
10 11 12 13 14 years old and all the
time when she goes to these people
all i want to say to her is
this is superstition you're wasting your
money you're wasting
your time leave them alone my mother
couldn't read all right
so i didn't know a way of expressing
that
and then soon after in 1985 i was 15
years old when
members of the muslim brotherhood came
along
and they finally convinced my mother and
grandmother and
all the women in our neighborhoods do
not
reach out to the
superstitious don't go to the witch
doctors
come to god one and only read the quran
they can't read the quran so they have
to trust in what he tells them
the hadith muhammad's way of doing
things
and in a way i felt
i felt grateful to the people who had
shepherded the women
of the grown up women of my life away
from these superstitious people
to the one and two and only god
it just happened to be another
superstition
better organized more slick
but at the time you didn't think so at
the time i didn't think so of course at
the time i completely believed in it
why did you why did you know
that the witch doctors were just
superstitious and that it was nonsense
at such an early age i'm in fourth grade
i had the fortune to actually go to
school and be taught such things as
science to the science class biology
cause and effect the way things happen
one of the things that ravaged
us was malaria i got malaria everybody i
know got malaria most people
had families where people died
people got sick really very sick and
then died
and the witch doctors were supposed to
make these people
well and they were at any rate supposed
to stop them from dying
so going to the biology class when we
were told
literally to look at
an insect called a mosquito and
dissect it and look at its behavior
and how it sees still water lays its
eggs
and what happens when that mosquito
comes
and injects its
what you call it that little
piece of itself into you draws your
blood and
leaves something in you which is the
parasite once you understand that and
this is
i'm in fourth grade fifth grade once
they teach that and they show how it
works
you go home and you say don't give any
more money to the witch doctor
actually what we should do is go around
to all the little
puddles and pools of water around us
let's
drain those dry those keep our windows
shut
we had this big can of
pesticide called doom and
i would say let's pray those after we
had done all of that
and we wouldn't have malaria because
that's how it
so i found myself even at that age
confronting grown-ups who are
established
who are well-respected and who were
taking
money from my poor mother because
they would cure malaria and i come
in i mean with the most
superficial level of education you can
think but objective
education to say i actually get what's
happening
and that i can't explain
to an american audience the
confrontation
the just the boundaries that you're
crossing
and and the people you're making angry
the toes you're stepping on
when you you know you breeze into the
house and say
and now i know how it works hmm
so you
as a as a young woman were going to be
forced into an arranged marriage and
this is what
made you flee and and head to europe and
and
wind up in holland correct that's
correct yeah
can you explain how that was going down
so this is 1992 and by then i'm 22 years
old
so we've been in kenya from 1980 to in
my case 1992.
my father left us in 1982
and i was about 12 years old and all
this time he was gone he was gone for 10
years
and he comes back and he says it's time
for you to get married
you hadn't seen him in 10 years i hadn't
seen him in 10 years
had he communicated with him at all he
used to write letters
and after a while the letter stopped
but the point in terms of
these him taking the duty upon himself
it's his duty so
the way it works in somali culture in
many parts of the world that culture is
the father is responsible
for who he's your guardian he's your
male guardian he's responsible
for who he's going to pass you on to
that's finding the right husband
because he was gone from 82 to 1992
a i was able to get on with age and get
stronger and wiser but also see some of
my classmates
and my friends who were forced
into these arranged marriages
and my takeaway from looking at their
lives was
i don't want my life to unfold that way
because it was really a replication of
my own mother's life
and my mother's life was miserable every
country we went to my mom didn't speak
the language she didn't want to learn
the language
but she felt betrayed she felt out of
depth
she was angry she was full of resentment
and she took it all out on us
so watching what was happening to these
young women i thought
surely life must offer more than that
and i to this day
say i am grateful that my father
left us when he did and came back when
he did
because had he been with us earlier
he might have taken this initiative to
force me into marriage at the age of 15
16 17 and at that
age i'm not sure i would have
accomplished what i did at
22.
and when he was gone i missed him
and i was miserable i wanted him to come
back and be with us
but then again everything is about
hindsight in hindsight i think
what if he had married me off at 15 or
16 or 17 or 18
you know what kind of future would i
have had
the environment that you lived in you
felt like women
were second-class citizens and you felt
like they were
the property of men and they were at
the beck and call of ben and
they were they weren't allowed to speak
up
they weren't allowed to do many things
that men were allowed to do and
they had to know their plays yes how
frustrating was that
it was hugely frustrating
also i'm not trying to defend where i
come from
but joe when i listen to you talk like
that
what i want to say is i know you've got
an
american western
um attitude so you're observing them
through that prism through the lens of
oh these women are oppressed and they
aren't allowed to do
anything and it's it's objectively true
i wholeheartedly agree with you and
there's so many women in that in those
positions who agree with you
but being on the inside being raised
within that culture when
you complain about the absolute
obedience that you have to show
to your father and other male relatives
um
when you talk when you object to the
fact that you're not supposed to have a
will of your own
or desires of your own or things you
wanted to do
the put down was always that you are the
rebel
you're sinning you are
you're breaking the rules and the laws
and the norms and the customs
so you are wrong and
there would be conversations between my
mother and her relatives
on how can we bring her back
into the straight path if you will
the religious edicts the tribal and clan
edicts
and that's where things when things get
out of hand because from one day
you are the insider they try to mold you
into the insider's beliefs and norms
you fail to do that and if you're not
careful you'll be made
the outsider were you unique amongst
your friends and the people in your
family in your beliefs
that this was wrong no i was not alone
uh there were girls and women around me
whom
i i really consider them to be
so much smarter stronger
more informed in many ways wiser
who i would look up to they might be two
or three years older than me and i would
say well
i'm really having a hard time right now
with
my mother and sticking to the rules how
do you do it
how have you done it and the answers i
would get most often
would be you're young you will learn
there's no way out of here so what you
need to do is
show willpower show strength
show commitment everybody goes through
this
for some it will be harder than others
but
the cons the thing i was told constantly
is
it's as hard as you make it in other
words
the sooner you submit
the sooner all these hardships go away
and then you're just one of us and
you're doing what you're supposed to
do what you were created to do by god
you're taking your place
the more you say i'm not going to do
this i'm going to read this novel it's
not my time to do the dishes it's
someone else's turn
you start fantasizing about where you
think you could be
then you are stepping on so many toys at
that point
and you know there's nobody who's gonna
be on your side
so you can make the pain as long as you
wanted it to be
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data
cost all for free spotify is absolutely
free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience